deux trois quarts
carte conseil d'ami c'est quoi c'est
qu'on fait parce que zelko et vous devez
donner un conseil à maurice barthélémy
pour lui expliquer comment faire avec
judith godrèche sept cas vraiment à
lestrem on sait qu'un forban d'une autre
mais il sait très bien faire et c'est
très très bien ah oui on allait se passe
bien mais très très bien et voilà il
monfils nouvelle il adore d'ailleurs
c'est un super beau père il a fait un
très bon film en plus papa ouais karch
si vous devez nous chanter les corons de
pierre bachelet en pleurant en pleurant
tu connais les corps oui bien sûr c'est
novateur chez tous les corps les hommes
des videurs de fonds